[Musica]
interno cinema anteo salas tra giorno
una piccola sala cinematografica con una
cinquantina di persone sedute tra il
pubblico
la maggior parte sono ragazzi sui 25 30
anni
sul palco vuoto illuminato e allestita
una scritta tridimensionale ed ex
università iulm salon
il pubblico in silenzio in attesa che
qualcuno salga sul palco qualche
mormorio di fondo riempie la sala
dietro le quinte c'è amina 26 anni la
prossima speaker che dovrà parlare alla
conferenza
è agitata pensa che avere accettato di
parlare in pubblico su un palco
registrata da telecamere sia la peggior
scelta che abbia mai fatto nella sua
vita ma ormai è lì e deve farlo
per rompere il ghiaccio a mina ha deciso
di proiettare una slide sullo schermo
del cinema è una pagina di sceneggiatura
lentamente quando il pubblico termine la
lettura a mina si fa strada sul palco
incerta
si schiarisce la voce guarda il pubblico
e finalmente prende parola
buongiorno a tutti sono mila grenci e il
lavoro come editor in una casa di
produzione non è mai facile parlare del
mio lavoro ma per farla breve sono
pagata per leggere e commentare
sceneggiature o più in generale idee
poi guardando il pubblico all'improvviso
il suo respiro si blocca il suo sguardo
si fissa su qualcosa che ha visto panico
non è più in grado di parlare
seguiamo il suo sguardo fino a rivelare
che li tra il pubblico c'è leonardo di
caprio che la guarda
in quel momento parte una musica over
careless whisper di george michael
poi in un istante leonardo scompare era
solo un miraggio
buongiorno a tutti sono a mina grenci
lavoro come editor in una casa di
produzione di anticipo già che leonardo
non è qui il resto della scena non è
andata come previsto e se non è andata
come previsto probabilmente è per colpa
di una persona che fa il mio lavoro
appunto fa l'editor ma facciamo un passo
indietro nel momento in cui uno
sceneggiatore ha un'idea per una storia
a la sfortunata idea anche di proporla
una casa di produzione e nel momento in
cui lo fa dovrebbe mettersi l'anima in
pace da subito e accettare il fatto che
probabilmente la maggior parte delle sue
idee andranno incontro alla realtà e la
realtà vuol dire esigenze non solo di
budget ma anche editoriali e produttive
adesso capiremo in che senso
quando uno sceneggiatore ha un'idea e la
propone una casa di produzione
troverà una persona tipo me che ascolta
la sua idea e nel momento in cui
quell'idea convince si entra in una fase
chiamata sviluppo che è quella di cui mi
occupo io e la fase di sviluppo può
durare anche anni è lunghissima e la
sceneggiatura è soltanto l'ultima delle
fasi dello sviluppo
entriamo nel pratico cosa cosa succede
nel momento in cui un idea ci convince
arriva una sceneggiatura e il nostro
compito il compito dell'editor è quello
di fare delle note le note sono vere e
proprie annotazioni che tu fai sul
foglio tipo professoressa del liceo con
la penna rossa e vai ad evidenziare
quelle che possono essere le
problematiche di quella scena non
soltanto a livello editoriale quindi
banalmente la storia i dialoghi gli
archi di personaggi ma anche appunto a
livello produttivo
entrando più nel pratico facciamo finta
che questa scena che spero si legga
questa scena
faccia parte di una sceneggiatura che
noi abbiamo accettato di sviluppare
e adesso vi faccio vedere come
normale giornata di lavoro agiscono su
una di queste scene sembra credo una
scena piuttosto coerente normale in
realtà nasconde 9 problematiche adesso
vediamo tutti insieme
il primo problema è propio
nell'intestazione cinema anteo
perché perché qualcuno dovrà chiedere
l'autorizzazione all'anteo per poter
girare in questo cinema e quindi ci sarà
una location manager che insieme
all'organizzatore dovranno occuparsi di
venire qui chiedere l'autorizzazione per
mille motivi diversi dante o potrebbe
non non concederla oppure potrebbe
essere fuori budget per noi oppure quel
giorno in cui serve può essere occupata
ci possono essere mille motivazioni in
ogni caso una cosa da tenere a mente
il secondo problema è proprio tra il
pubblico
25 30 anni e l'unica cosa che sappiamo
però se questo film è ambientato nel
2021 non si può prescindere dal fatto
che può skovde in novembre 2021 non è
credibile che le persone in un cinema
non indossano la mascherina e quindi è
una cosa che in realtà va detta e va
scritta e anche ma anche per chi lavora
nel reparto per esempio di costumi nel
momento in cui
c'è bisogno di procurarsi una
cinquantina di mascherine chi lavora
nelle parti mi deve saperlo e non va
lasciato
sottointeso
un'altra problematica qui ce ne sono ben
due in realtà è che stiamo nominando due
brand sia ted che gli olmi
entrambi hanno bisogno di
un'autorizzazione bisogna chiedere
l'autorizzazione per poterli nominare
per poter usare i loro brand per poterle
mostrare per qualunque motivo che sia
d'immagine che sia di marketing che sia
anche appunto proprio di interesse
personale potrebbero non concedere
l'autorizzazione
un'altra problematica il dietro le
quinte il 3 le quinte non è più la
lastra e dietro le quinte della sala
astra è un altro un'altra location e
questo significherebbe dover aprire
un'altra scena e quindi a interno cinema
anteo sala astra quinte per evitare di
aprire un'altra scena si potrebbe
semplicemente integrare la posizione di
amina all'interno di questa scena in un
dietro le quinte poi dopo andremo a
vedere in che modo
amina 26 anni possiamo caratterizzare
maggiormente il personaggio
immaginate una casting director che ha
bisogno di trovare un attrice che
interpreta nina in questo momento è
l'unica informazione che ha e la sua età
26 anni nel fine non ha una idea della
statura del colore dei capelli di
un'idea che c'è dietro questo
personaggio che andrebbe sicuramente
profondità di più qui arriva il punto in
realtà più problematico probabilmente
nella prima pagina di qualunque manuale
di sceneggiatura e spiegato che tutto
ciò che scriviamo in una sceneggiatura
deve potersi tradurre in immagini e
quindi il verbo pensare in realtà
dovrebbe quasi essere abolito dalle
sceneggiature perché è impossibile
riuscire a vedere il pensiero di un
personaggio a meno che poi non si crei
una scena parte in cui entriamo nel
pensiero del personaggio ma non è questo
il caso e quindi come facciamo a capire
che amina si pensi a pensando che la
peggior scelta la sua vita sia essere
qui su questo palco stasera se non la
verbalizza se non riusciamo a capire
nessun modo
stessa cosa vale appunto per per rompere
il ghiaccio la sua intenzione noi non
possiamo capirla semplicemente da questa
scena così come descritta e quindi come
capiamo quello che sta pensando troviamo
soluzioni visive
poi il dialogo per farla breve sono
pagata per diciamo che non è poi così
professionale appunto e non è magari
adatto al contesto e quindi troviamo
espressioni più formali professionali
ecco qui arriva il grande problema
leonardo che non ha accettato di essere
qui oggi perché perché chiaramente
per realizzare questa scena così come
scritta avremmo davvero bisogno di
chiamare leonardo di caprio è
chiaramente
immaginate dalla casting director che
chiama la gente di di chiavi cabriolet
chiede non è che per caso leonardo può
venire a milano per sedersi un attimo
una mezz'oretta su una sedia a guardare
una probabilmente no e magari sì magari
accetterebbe anche male accettasse forse
il suo cachet cinque volte l'intero
budget del film
è un altro problema è proprio la musica
che l suisse per è una canzone
meravigliosa perfetta per questi momenti
ma probabilmente molto costosa e quindi
se proprio non necessaria troviamo
un'alternativa più economica
a questo punto cosa succede
sceneggiatore ha ricevuto le nostre note
non così incasinate ma scritte su un
foglio word e magari anche decorate un
po probabilmente non dirà cose carine
nei nostri confronti però dopo di che si
siederà al computer e si metterà la
farete su modifiche vediamo in che modo
può aver integrato le nostre note nella
nuova versione
cinema neo diventa sala cinema generica
quindi possiamo ricostruirla magari in
the altro possiamo scegliere un altro
cinema per qualunque motivo non temo non
ha accettato o noi non siamo stati in
grado di poter girare in cui la location
e quindi bisogna trovarne un altro
abbiamo aggiunto che
tutti la mascherina ed è fondamentale
abbiamo già subito
riposizionato il film in una
nel tempo e nello spazio appunto quindi
sappiamo che post co lead
negli ul nel ted ci hanno concesso di
utilizzare il loro brand e quindi
bisogna inventarsi n'è uno nuovo bisogna
farsene una nuova che possa avere la
stessa efficacia che possa far capire lo
stesso intento e allora university talks
potrà andare per il momento qui non
c'erano errori
all'altra del palco c'è amica quindi
l'abbiamo reintegrata in questa scena
una scena è la stessa
l'intenzione è la stessa cioè amina non
è in vista non è sul palco ma nell'atto
del palco e l'abbiamo caratterizzata
maggiormente una ragazza alta e bionda
il volto terrorizzato e a un microfono
ad archetto questo non è vero ed ecco
come abbiamo reso per immagini la sua
frustrazione e la sua paura la mia
agitata si tortura le mani si muove
nervosamente
guarda il cielo si porta le mani al
volto e sussurra tra sé ma chi me l'ha
fatto fare
diciamo che in questa così scritta
magari il fatto che lei non sia proprio
nella comfort son si comincia a capire e
mentre il suo momento si avvicina sullo
schermo del cinema viene proiettato
il dialogo diventa leggermente più
professionale non lavoro in una casa di
produzione ma lavora come editor di
indiana production il mio lavoro
consiste soprattutto nel leggere e
valutare le sceneggiature
ed eccoci a leonardo allora per il
momento arriva da di caprio rimasto in
scena ma qual è il diversivo che lo
sceneggiatore ha trovato l'immagine
sfocata quindi potrebbe in realtà non
essere lui spoiler non è lui
in quel momento parte la musica over
romantica quindi careless whisper non
non ce l'hanno concesso comunque costava
decisamente troppo l'importante che sia
romantica l'importante che dia quel quel
senso e quindi poi si deciderà e chi si
occuperà delle musiche deciderà quale
musica possa essere più adatta a questo
momento che possa avvicinarsi il più
possibile a careless whisper poi
l'immagine si fa più nitida quel ragazzo
non è leonardo di caprio ma solo
qualcuno che gli somiglia quindi il
senso della scena e lo stesso cioè a
mina si blocca perché crede di aver
visto di caprio però non è di capri un
suo sosia che sicuramente ci costerà un
quinto di
tutto questo perché
io nella vita ho l'aspirazione di
diventare una sceneggiatrice e prima di
fare questo lavoro non avevo idea di
quanto la sceneggiatura sia fondamentale
per ogni reparto che lavora al film
quanto sia fondamentale e non non sia
soltanto una questione come molti
pensano di appunto storia i personaggi e
il documento tecnico per eccellenza il
quale fanno riferimento tutti i reparti
e lavorano un film ed è tanto più
preciso quanto più i reparti lavoreranno
meglio io chiaramente gli auguro un
giorno di poter scrivere un film per il
quale è di caprio sarà disposto a
prendere un aereo per stare seduto 30
secondi su una sedia non è questo il
caso
ma sicuramente tenere a mente nel
momento in cui si va a scrivere una
sceneggiatura di quante variabili ci
siano in ballo di quanti problematiche
possa
causare un semplice pensiero
penso che posso aiutarvi quantomeno a
superare uno step di note grazie
[Applauso]